[Music]
juneteenth rallies happening across the
country as racial turmoil
appears to be influencing joe biden's
search for a running mate
amy klobuchar says she's bowing out take
a look
i truly believe as i actually told the
vice president last night
when i called him that i think this is a
moment
to put a woman of color on that ticket
if you want to
heal this nation right now my party yes
but our nation this is sure a
hell of a way to do it
and with klobuchar out kamala harris's
odds are rising a new poll shows
democrats favor harris
by a wide margin but will the radical
left accept her past as a prosecutor
harris trying to spin her resume as a
positive
watch this i know the system from the
inside out i strongly believe
if we are going to change these systems
there has to be the kind of brilliant
activism that we've seen from the
outside like
black lives matter and the leadership
there combined with what we need to do
on the inside to actually
upend these systems in a way that we
make change to get closer to that ideal
we have of equal justice under the law
all right jessie i'm going to start with
you you know amy klobuchar i don't know
if she had something in her throat or if
she was just choking back tears
but she has always been extremely
ambitious has wanted to be
president and certainly vice president
but when she says she's bowing out for
because the vice because the president
should pick
vp biden if he's president should pick a
vp
of color do you think that's the reason
she's bowing out could there be another
reason
a vulnerability in fact
yeah that's like it's like me saying i'm
withdrawing my name for consideration to
be
president trump's vp pick right now i
just want to make sure everybody knows
that
i think carmel is now the top choice and
she's got some negatives i think she's a
cheap shot artist
she doesn't really have policy chops
domestic or
foreign she was a terrible manager of
her campaign
totally dysfunctional doesn't have the
executive authority needed
and you know biden's running is this
kind of one-term holdover
so i don't know if she's totally
trustworthy she might leak and kind of
try to stab
him in the back i'm not really sure
she's gonna she's gonna cut it but
she also has a lot of positives she
raised a lot of money
she i like her litigator style extremely
tenacious when she gets these
witnesses in her crosshairs she really
just rips their throat right out i've
never seen anything like it
and that's maybe what you want as an
attack dog on the on
the vp ticket so you know
she's got a great background that people
do like uh you know her father
uh indian um or her mother um i think it
was
jamaican immigrants she married a jewish
man
people love that type of melting pot
story
she looks very attractive on television
and you know my thing dana
the bumper sticker biden harris
it it fits that works nice and short
i like it all right greg greg i'm going
to go to you
all right so you've got her saying
kamela harris you know because i've been
a prosecutor i know the system inside
out
and i can change it and i'm not just a
prosecutor
and take it from me we put people in
jail
uh that's kind of what we do when they
commit crimes
and we convict them beyond a reasonable
doubt but she says i'm a progressive
prosecutor what is a progressive
prosecutor
well first i want to address what jessie
said that kamala doesn't have to stab
or might stab joe in the back she
doesn't have to stab joe in the back
all she has to do is scare him and uh i
don't know why we're all
jumping to kamala harris
because amy klobuchar said a woman of
color
all right and you're all like
overlooking liz warren
which makes no sense to me um i think
what amy did
what amy did was really smart she saw
the writing on the wall
she knew that the decision was already
made so she wanted to act like it was
her own idea
somebody said to her hey i heard biden's
gonna pick uh
kamala harris and then she goes you know
what it has a press conference that says
we should uh
choose uh he should choose a woman of
color it's like when you find out that
you're about to be fired
and right before they say hey you're
fired you say no i quit
you don't get the severance but at least
your pride's intact
and we all know that joe is just a seed
filler for the academy like the c filler
for this job
she's whoever's getting picked is going
to be the president the president if he
wins yeah
but but you know dana klobuchar just to
put her away for now i mean klobuchar
was a prosecutor who
refused to prosecute police brutality
in minneapolis including the particular
officer chauvin
so i mean she's got a lot of problems
but more importantly
um with val demings for example i mean
there you have someone
who has made a name for herself somewhat
in the impeachment hearings
uh but she was a police chief and how do
you think that will
rub black lives matter
it's interesting that you um went to
that because that was exactly what i was
thinking because
jesse and greg stole my two jokes or
actually
i was gonna steal theirs um but um i
guess i can't be the
in the running to be quarterback for the
broncos because i was never in the
running to be the quarterback for the
broncos
but part of the things about that
happened with klobuchar is because of
the focus of minneapolis and george
floyd
and her reign there up in
minnesota she was not going to be the
vice presidential choice so i agree
like she definitely saw that coming so
she said i'm just going to step
graciously out of the way
but to your point so val demings is a
congresswoman from
orlando area of florida she was a police
officer
law enforcement background she was a
police chief one of the things that
happened today is you had some
new york state-based black lives matter
spokesperson say she is
not going to be somebody that we would
ever support
because she did not do enough to deal
with police brutality when she was a
police officer
so i think that when it comes to the
vice presidential choice the number one
thing for any presidential candidate
choosing a vice president
is do no harm so when you have somebody
like val demings who
most of the country doesn't know you
have to take it would take a lot of
effort to introduce her
to the nation somebody like kamala
harris already has that name id so that
can help you
and he also has to think about one of
two things
does he need somebody that he wants to
work with as a partner
when he if he were to become president
or does he need someone that will help
shore up the left wing of the democratic
party and does he think
that person can do that i think no
matter who it is
and when you see if whatever that
person's attributes are
that will be what he's more concerned
about
well and juan though
all three kamala harris and um
the the police officer val demings um
you know both of them
those two i should say have law
enforcement background klobuchar did as
well
but elizabeth warren in terms of what
dana was saying do no harm
she doesn't have a law enforcement
background she's got a
strong people know who she is she's very
much a progressive
she's very aggressive when it comes to
she would be all harm
is that what you think juan
well i thought dana said something i
dana i want to finish her thought
well i i just i think that elizabeth
warren if there's no upside
for joe biden and when you when i say do
no harm she is the opposite of that she
is all harm
to him if he were to pick her but
the law enforces women are harm as well
because they cannot get away from their
law enforcement background
each one of those campbell harris spent
decades prosecuting go ahead juan
okay so i disagree with you i in fact
would think that for a lot of people in
the suburbs the idea that you have
somebody with law enforcement background
is not a negative i think there's an
intense focus among
among us here on the five on kind of the
far
left uh at this moment in terms of
thinking about the negatives that come
especially in the aftermath of george
floyd's death from
people who are concerned about excessive
use of force and law enforcement records
i think it did hurt klobuchar
and in case of demings i think the big
problem is lack of national name
recognition
uh but so it leaves in my mind uh
harris and elizabeth warren some people
still talking about stacy abrams the
former
uh state rep from georgia who's very
powerful voice very smart woman
but when you look at it you know you
think of it in terms of black voters and
wanting to make sure black voter turnout
is strong in november for biden
i'm surprising that warren consistently
posed well with black
voters and harris i think also has
these issues but guess what she too is
popular
uh so to me it's between the two of them
i think demings is
kind of interesting you know an
afterthought at this point i would just
point out
warren i think she and biden raised six
million dollars in one
video uh fundraiser this week it was
astounding
astonishing and uh again speaks to the
strength
that she would bring to that ticket all
right